[Music]  the star celebrated the most patriotic  day of the year in style here's how our  favorite celebs paid tribute to the red  white and blue Vanessa Hudgens ever the  dancer partied by the pool with some  girlfriends meanwhile her BFF Ashley  Tisdale put her fit physique on full  display in a star print one-piece I love  it  Nicole Scherzinger was red-hot on a  yacht and bella thorne went all-american  in a swimsuit and jeans  equally spirited sofia vergara who was  clearly the hostess with the mostess  her hubby Joe Manganiello was on grill  Patrol you're too hot too sexy  they're gone and let's not forget the  fourth of July is also a big family day  Rob Kardashian cooled off in the pool  with his daughter dream Ally Barry took  her kids on a nature walk and always  living on the edge Mariah Carey who took  her twins to swim with sharks  [Music]  Oh